[Music]
foreign
so we've been talking about numerical
integration of ordinary differential
equations and in particular we've been
deriving the forward Euler and backward
Euler approximations now in general our
whole point of integrating uh kind of
ordinary differential equations
numerically is that we want to be able
to integrate or predict the trajectory
of a non-linear system of different
differential equations x dot equals f of
x where f is a non-linear function but
to understand things like the error
properties and the stability properties
it can be very helpful to look at the
simpler case where we are integrating a
linear differential equation x dot
equals ax where we kind of know the
answer of course we know the solution of
this is X of T equals e to the a times
time times our initial condition
X naught maybe I'll just you know write
that down of course we know that the
solution of this linear system is x sub
T equals e to the a t times the initial
condition so we don't need to use a
numerical integrator to solve this
linear system but we can use this linear
system to look at how are kind of the
generic stability properties of forward
Euler and backward Euler so this is the
forward Euler scheme assuming our
Dynamics are linear
and the backward Euler scheme assuming
our Dynamics are linear so if I have my
my system State X at time step K I can
get it at the next time step K plus 1
which is one delta T in the future by
multiplying my current state with this
Matrix identity plus delta T times a and
similarly backward Euler I multiply my
current Step at my current state by
identity Matrix minus delta T A inverse
and that will give me my next my state
at the next time step so we derived
these in the last few lectures and we
noticed that the forward Euler scheme in
particular when I had a large enough
delta T it went unstable okay meaning
even though the original dynamical
system x dot equals ax was stable and
had kind of negative real part for the
eigenvalues and should Decay to zero are
integrator approximation blew up to
Infinity that's what I mean by unstable
and who can blame it every once in a
while all of us feel a little bit
unstable but we'd like to understand
when and how the system goes unstable
we'd like to be able to diagnose and
predict the instability of these
integrators and maybe that'll give us a
way of controlling delta T to make sure
that our integrator is stable in the
future again we eventually want to apply
this to non-linear systems X naught
equals f of x but we can still learn a
lot by these kind of linear analyzes
this is kind of how you do it
classically and I think it builds a lot
of good intuition
good now before I jump into this
full-blown hairy Matrix system of
equations and show you the stability in
this example I think what I want to do
is I need to just give you a couple of
Notions of what I mean by stability in
general and then we're going to look at
the simpler case where this is a scalar
x dot equals Lambda X those we're going
to build this up kind of uh very
methodically and systematically because
there's some kind of complicated
Concepts here that I want to I want to
work out for you okay
so the first thing
too is the notion of stability
so
we know that if we have something like x
dot equals Lambda X
then the solution of this is e to the
Lambda t
times x naught right this is my solution
X at time T this is x t is e to the
Lambda T times x naught
and so
this system is stable
if Lambda has negative real part so
again let's just assume that Lambda
equals you know a plus or minus i b so
it's got a real and an imaginary part
then we know that e to the Lambda t
equals e to the a t
times cosine b t plus I
sine of B
T and so what I'm pointing out here this
is just Euler's formula essentially what
I'm pointing out here is that the
imaginary part of the Lambda that I'm
taking the exponential of the imaginary
part just gives us Sines and cosines and
Sines and cosines always have magnitude
one like the you know if I if I take
cosine squared plus I plus sine squared
that always adds up to one and so this
doesn't blow up or Decay so if I just
had a purely imaginary eigenvalue Lambda
equals plus or minus IB my system
wouldn't blow up or Decay it would be
neutrally stable okay and so the
stability really comes from this real
part so stability
stability comes
from the real part
of Lambda which we're calling a and so
if a is less than zero if this real part
is negative
then all of this oscillating stuff gets
multiplied by a decaying exponential
this
you know e to the a t is decaying if a
is negative
so we call this stable
because it converges to the origin to x
equals zero so this stably decays and if
a is greater than zero
then all of this stuff gets multiplied
by each of the positive a times time
which means it all gets multiplied by
this growing exponential this growing e
to the a t and it blows up to Infinity
as time goes on we call that unstable
so that is what we mean by stable and
unstable for these systems this is a
review just a really really quick review
if I have x dot equals Lambda X
the solution is e to the Lambda T and
the real part of Lambda because again
Lambda could have complex it could be a
complex number the real part of Lambda
the the a part here the real part if
it's negative it's stable and if it's
positive it's unstable that's just kind
of how this has always worked okay and
that is this whole picture that I've
drawn over here is what we call
continuous time this is what we call
continuous
time
because we're taking a continuous
derivative DX DT and this is kind of
continually this function gives me a
continuous a smooth continuous X as a
function of time
now there is a
similar notion for discrete time
differential equations
where instead of x dot equals Lambda X
we could have x k plus 1 equals Lambda x
k and we're going to iterate this system
forward in time so this is what we're
going to call discrete time
and I hope you can see that our
integrators are forward and backward
Euler integrators are essentially
discrete time systems that are trying to
approximate our continuous time
differential equation so what we mean by
stability and continuous time and
discrete time are a little bit different
so in discrete time the solution of my
system is you know I kind of have
something like X1 equals Lambda X naught
and X2 equals Lambda X1 and X you know K
plus one dot dot dot equals Lambda X
K and so I can kind of back substitute
this so that X2 equals Lambda times X1
which is Lambda times x naught so it's
Lambda squared times x naught and you
know X3 is Lambda cubed times x naught
and x k plus 1 you guessed it it's
Lambda to the K plus 1 times x naught
so here
stability means does this Lambda to the
K plus 1 blow up to infinity or Decay
down to zero okay so again stability
this is stable
if Lambda to the K plus 1 goes to zero
as K goes to infinity and it's unstable
if Phi
it's unstable if Lambda K plus 1 blows
up to infinity or you know negative
Infinity if the absolute value of this
blows up to Infinity as K goes to
Infinity so it means that
synthetically stability means that this
trajectory goes to zero and instability
means it blows up to Infinity but now
we're not talking about e to an a t or e
to the minus a t we're talking about
Lambda to a power k for this discrete
time system
and so how do we think about this if I
think about any complex number this
again this Lambda could be a complex
number
so let's say I have you know
Lambda and I'm going to choose this is a
complex number I'm going to choose to
write this in polar coordinates so it
has some radius and some Theta
we know that Lambda squared equals the
radius squared e to the so this Lambda
equals radius e to the I Theta
and Lambda squared is radius squared e
to the i 2 Theta
dot dot dot Lambda to the power K is
radius to the k e to the I
K Theta and so similarly
increasing K this e to the I Theta e to
the i 2 theta 3 Theta 4 Theta K Theta
This thing always has unit length in the
complex plane it always has unit length
and the length of the Specter is this
kind of radius or radius squared or
radius to the k
so this
this thing blows up
if
the radius
is bigger than one
okay so this thing is unstable
if the radius
is greater than one if the radius of
Lambda if the length of Lambda is bigger
than one in the complex plane because
then I'll get you know something that's
let's say it's two then the radius is 2
Lambda squared is four Lambda cubed is 8
16 32 64 it's going to blow up Lambda to
the K is two times bigger than Lambda to
the K minus 1. and so if the radius is
bigger than one even if this is
1.0001 eventually that to a really big
power is going to go unstable
so if the radius of Lambda and the
radius again if Lambda equals a plus I B
then the radius is just the square root
of the real part squared plus the
imaginary part squared that's what I
mean by the the length or the radius of
this complex number if the radius is
bigger than one it blows up and it's
unstable as I take powers of the radius
and it is stable
if the radius is less than one okay if
the radius is less than one like let's
say it's a half then when I Square it
now it's a quarter then an eight then a
sixteenth and it contracts to to zero
and similarly even if this is just
barely less than one if it's 0.99999
eventually 0.9999999 to the really big
power is going to go to zero okay so
that was a lot this is like the first
half uh maybe the first third of this
lecture so I'm going to pause here and
recap this is super important
um
if I have a differential equation x
naught equals Lambda X we have a lot of
intuition for what it means for a
solution to be stable or unstable a
stable solution will have lambdas with a
negative real part A negative real part
A so that so that we have a negative
damped uh solution that decays to zero
an unstable solution will have a
positive real part that blows up to
Infinity as T goes on that's what we
mean to be stable or unstable for a
continuous time differential equation
for a discrete time update equation like
this like our our integrators where
we're taking these discrete steps from X
0 to X1 and X1 to X2 and X2 to X3
now stability has to do not with e to
the Lambda but with Lambda to a power k
and so if Lambda to the power K blows up
it's unstable if we Lambda to the power
K blows up it's unstable and if Lambda
to the power K goes to zero it's stable
and if Lambda if this Lambda number here
could be a complex number then that
blowing up or decaying has to do with
the radius or the length of that complex
number in the complex plane literally
the length of that number is the square
root of a squared plus b squared okay
the real part plus the imaginary part
the square of the real part plus the
square of the imaginary part square root
that's radius
and if that radius
is larger than one this is going the
magnitude is going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and the thing is going
to blow up and if the radius is less
than one then it's going to contract to
the origin so instability for a discrete
time system has to do with the radius of
this number getting bigger than one and
stability of this discrete time system
this let's say in another way this
discrete time system is stable if the
radius the length of Lambda in the
complex plane is less than one and this
system is unstable if the length of
Lambda in the complex plane this R is
bigger than one good
okay now we're ready to look at the
stability of these integration schemes
and I'm going to start again for a
stable linear system we're going to look
at this discrete time update equation
and analyze its stability and then we're
going to go to the Matrix case I'm going
to erase some stuff and then look at the
stability for the scalar case
okay I just erased and I put a little
summary kind of decoder ring up here for
continuous time systems x dot equals
Lambda X the system is stable if the
real part of Lambda is less than zero
and it's unstable if the real part of
Lambda is greater than zero and
similarly for a discrete time system x k
plus 1 equals Lambda times x k this
system is stable if the radius of Lambda
if the length of Lambda in the complex
plane is less than one and it's unstable
if that radius or length of Lambda is
greater than one so we just want us to
remember that now what we're going to do
is we are going to imagine we have this
linear differential equation and we're
going to try to simulate it with forward
Euler and backward Oiler so we're going
to plug this into this expression here
and we're going to see are there Delta
T's that make this discrete time system
go unstable even though this pink
continuous time system was stable to
begin with so that's kind of
[Music]
where we're going to to go with this
okay so generally speaking what I'm
going to do is I'm going to assume that
this was actually a stable system I'm
going to assume that Lambda was an
honest-to-goodness stable system
um because why would I be you know
simulating this if I think it's going to
blow up to Infinity but maybe maybe that
way but let's just assume this is stable
you don't really need to
uh and what we're going to do is we're
going to write down forward and backward
Oilers specifically for this um for this
case here so forward Euler
for this scalar linear differential
equation is just x k plus one
identity is just one this is not a
matrix system it's a scalar system so
this is literally
one plus Lambda delta T
times x k
so now this is a discrete time system
where this is I should probably should
have called this beta where this is
maybe I'll do that so all of this is
true even for some dummy variable if I
called this uh
oh squeaky
even if I call this a beta so let's say
this was you know beta times x k
so a discrete time system x k plus 1
equals beta times x k is stable if the
radius of beta is less than one if this
and it's unstable if the radius of beta
and the complex plane is greater than
one
so this
uh forward Euler system this is kind of
the beta of this discrete time system
here and we'll find out that for some
delta T even if this Lambda was
continuous times stable this forward
Euler approximation might be unstable
for some big delta T that's what we're
about to find out okay
good uh so that's forward Oiler and then
similarly backward oil I'm just going to
write it down it's a backward Oiler
is X K plus 1 equals again inverse is
just one over so this is
um you know one minus Lambda delta T
inverse x k that's just you know 1 over
1 minus Lambda delta T and similarly
this is the beta or the discrete time
you know update Constant for backward
Euler okay that's that's these are
discrete time approximations of this
continuous time system
and so of course if I take my forward
Euler
and I stepped the system forward in time
so what we're doing is we're going you
know x0 to X1 kind of x0 to X1
to x 2 to dot dot dot to X big n
x 0 to X1 I multiply it by Beta X1 to X2
I multiply it by Beta x 2 to X3 and so
on and so forth and so essentially x n
here x n
is equal to this beta
1 plus Lambda delta T
to the power n
times x not okay and again when this I'm
just going to underscore this as beta
this is again this is you know Now Beta
to the power n when this beta has a
radius or length in the complex plane
that's bigger than one this thing's
going to go unstable even if Lambda is
stable a negative real part this is
going to blow up okay so that's what
we're going to find and similarly you
know for this one here it's pretty easy
to show that x n is equal to something
like you know 1 over 1 minus Lambda
delta T
to the power n x naught and again so so
similarly when this number is larger
than one has a radius that's larger than
one this will blow up and when this
number has a radius that's smaller than
one it'll be stable okay and so
essentially this uh forward Euler
forward Euler is uh stable it's unstable
when it's unstable
when this thing is larger than one when
one
plus Lambda delta T the magnitude the
this These Bars literally mean the
complex magnitude the the magnet if this
was a complex Lambda then the length of
that this number in the complex plane
when this number is greater than one
and similarly this number is
unstable
if you know 1 over 1 minus Lambda delta
T is greater than one
um
in general
we can we can start with just let's say
Lambda equals negative one okay when
Lambda equals negative one so definitely
this is a stable system there are
clearly Delta T's even if Lambda is
negative one that will make this system
have a radius larger than one okay so if
if Lambda was negative one and delta T
is ten
then one minus 10 is minus nine and
minus 9 has a radius of 9 and so it's
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger as I iterate the system so for a
delta T big enough clearly this is going
to go unstable there are some Delta T's
that will make this unstable but it's a
much smaller set as I'm about to show
you
okay so
um here is what I'm going to show you so
we're going to look at in the complex
plane so we're going to say
Z equals
Lambda delta T
so
um
given a Lambda and given a delta T both
of the stability of these depend on on
Lambda and delta T okay
what we find is that we have in the
complex plane we get these these
interesting stability regions
so this is for forward Euler this is the
complex plane and we're talking about
forward Euler
what we find
is that the system is only stable it's
only stable
for a unit radius Circle about the point
negative one so here we are stable
if Lambda times delta T so this is
um
Z equals Lambda delta T this is the Z
plane here
this forward Euler is only stable when Z
is
um
within a unit radius circle of the
negative one point
now I think you're going to probably
that if you can convince yourself this
is this becomes you know one plus Z
magnitude okay this Z is Lambda delta T
and this thing is going to be bigger
than one
any times Z is outside of this blue
circle that I've drawn anywhere inside
this blue circle right if Z equals
um if Z equals minus 0.5 that's totally
fine if Z equals minus one that's
totally fine if Z equals minus 1.5
that's totally fine like you can
convince yourself on the real line that
that it's only stable for here but if Z
is bigger than zero this will blow up
and if Z is bigger than negative two
this will also have a radius that's
bigger than one and blow up and you can
convince yourself that that's also true
you know if if Z was a complex number I
would literally plug in a plus IB here
and work out a condition for this to
have radius greater than one or equal to
one and you'll find this blue circle
and it is unstable everywhere else this
is terrible it's unstable everywhere
else in the complex plane and I hope
these colors come through because this
pink is unstable
so for Z equals Lambda T it is unstable
for a huge range of Lambda times delta T
particular if I fix
a number I pick out of a hat land is a
number then as I change delta T
most of the values of delta T are going
to make this forward Euler system
unstable
and you can convince your
zamda is a real number so Lambda times
delta T is only going to be on this real
line that's actually much easier you can
convince yourself that for a huge range
of delta T as I make delta T bigger and
bigger and bigger this Lambda times
delta T is going to move outside of this
stability region it's going to move into
the unstable region pretty quickly even
for moderate delta T
now let's look at what happens for
backward Oiler okay so I'm going to draw
the same axes we're in the same complex
plane with a z variable and this is now
for our backward Oiler
this is a little bit uh trickier to see
but essentially
these because we're taking one over one
minus delta T Lambda 1 over 1 minus Z
these
the shapes and sizes of the stable and
unstable region flip so I'm going to
draw it for you and then we're going to
try to reason why it looks like this
so for backward Euler the unstable
region actually is a small circle around
this is the unstable region unstable
much smaller
and then I have a massive part of the
complex plane where if Lambda times
delta T is anywhere in this blue region
the system is actually stable which is
way way better that's what we want we
want our system to be stable okay and so
this kind of gives at least a pictorial
understanding of why the forward Euler
is so easy to make unstable it's because
you know Lambda times delta T even for a
stable Lambda could easily be in this
unstable region if I make delta T big if
I make delta T big it's going to blow me
out of this stable region into this red
unstable region so it's really easy to
make forward Euler unstable by making
delta T big this this thing blows up
whereas in backward or implicit Oiler
making delta T big here doesn't actually
hurt me most of the time if I make delta
T like a bajillion I'm more or less
getting one over Lambda bajillion which
is going to be a very small number so
making delta T big
there is not actually a terrible thing
for stability and so I have a huge range
of stability for for backward Oiler and
only a small region of instability
okay so now we are going to be looking
at this General Matrix case where we
have x dot equals ax and again we can
assume that this differential equation
we're simulating has stable eigenvalues
so now uh stability up here in The
Matrix sense has to do with the
eigenvalues of a so for continuous time
um x dot equals ax is stable
if the real part of all of the
eigenvalues of a
are negative okay that's what we know
from linear systems theory is that this
is really messy sorry we know that this
system is stable
if the real part of like let's say
Lambda equals the eigenvalues of a
if all of these eigenvalues have real
part less than zero it's stable we know
that
and then similarly for a matrix update
equation let's say x k plus 1 equals m a
big Matrix times x k
this system similarly is going to be you
know x n equals this Matrix to the nth
power x naught
and so this system and I could take the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of M and T
equals t
d t d where D is a diagonal matrix of
eigenvalues
t d
uh and that would also give me that
m equals t d t inverse and so I can plug
this into m to the power m n and I get T
you'll notice that if I have t times D
times T inverse times another T times D
times T inverse times another one times
another one n times the T inverse T's
are going to cancel
just like we did when we computed The
Matrix exponential
and we're going to get t d to the power
n
T inverse where these are the
eigenvalues
of M
and so similarly just like here for a
matrix system this notion of stability
generalized to the eigenvalues of a
for a discrete update equation with a
matrix M this discrete time notion of
stability generalizes to the eigenvalues
of M so if the IGS of M if the radius
of these eigenvalues is greater than one
then we're unstable
and if the radius of these eigenvalues
of this m Matrix are less than one
then this will be stable okay so just
this is just a little bit to show you
how stability works for Matrix discrete
systems
and now we can take this basically this
now is my M Matrix this
is my M Matrix for forward Euler this
whole thing is my M Matrix for implicit
or backwards Euler and so essentially we
have two conditions we have that forward
Euler forward Euler
is stable
is stable when
the eigenvalues of this Matrix have
radius less than one so when uh the iges
of the identity plus delta T A
when these eigenvalues have radius in
the complex plane these are complex
numbers when they have you know modulus
or length in the complex plane less than
one then forward Euler is going to be
stable and when these eigenvalues if
even a single one of these eigenvalues
has a is a complex number with a radius
bigger than one then that scheme is
going to be unstable and blow up to
infinity and again for large delta T
it's very likely that these are going to
have unstable eigenvalues
okay similarly backward Oiler we can
write the same condition so backward
Oiler
is stable
when the eigenvalues of this update
Matrix have radius less than one so when
the eigenvalues of identity minus Delta
ta
inverse when these eigenvalues
have length in the complex plane less
than one backward Euler is going to be
stable and conversely if even a single
one of these eigenvalues has a radius
that's larger than one the backward
Euler scheme is going to go unstable
okay so this was a lot this was a heavy
lecture where we talked about you know
continuous time stability discrete time
stability we talked about you know
Solutions of linear continuous time
systems and how they relate to these
discrete time approximations these
forward Euler approximations
key key things I need you to take away
is that in continuous time stability has
to deal with the real part of your
eigenvalues the the real part has to be
negative for this to be stable whereas
in discrete time stability stability has
to do with the length or the radius of
those eigenvalues so if the radius or
the length of this number is bigger than
one my discrete time system is unstable
if it's less than one my discrete time
system is stable and you can use this
basic basic principle to analyze the
full stability properties of forward
Euler and backward Oiler even in this
full General Matrix system of equations
case
now that still doesn't tell me when I
will be stable for a generic non-linear
differential equation like x dot equals
f of x but it does build a lot of
intuition for how big of an instability
region forward Euler has and why
backward Euler is so much more stable
it's because backward Euler had a tiny
little circle where it's unstable in the
complex plane whereas forward Euler only
had a tiny little circle where it was
stable so generically backward Oiler is
a much more stable algorithm and it's
related to the properties of these kind
of update matrices M the eigenvalues of
those matrices
okay I hope that was helpful that was a
lot but that synthesized a lot of what
we learned up until now with eigenvalues
and eigenvectors and continuous time
systems and these discrete time update
equations all right thank you
[Music]